la séance est reprise
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
à des questions d'actualité au
gouvernement
je rappelle que l'auteur de la question
de même que le ou la ministre pour sa
réponse se disposent chacun de deux
minutes trente
je vous demanderais de bien vouloir vous
plier à cette règle qui est absolument
nécessaire au bon fonctionnement de nos
questions d'actualité la parole et pour
la première question à madame catherine
troendlé pour le groupe union pour un
mouvement populaire
monsieur le président mesdames messieurs
les ministres mes chers collègues ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre délégué chargé du budget
monsieur le ministre votre majorité a
été élu sur le mensonge pour prétendit
réconcilier les français entre eux vous
ne cessez de les monter les uns contre
les autres en proposant des lois de
société qui divise profondément les
français en opposant les salariés du
privé ceux du public avec la suppression
du jour de carence pour les ans tout
votre programme n'était que mensonges
vous avait abrogé la hausse de la tva
qui allait permettre de lutter contre
les délocalisations
trois mois plus tard vous l'avez
rétablis de manière plus longue et moins
efficace vous avez prétendu que votre
hausse des impôts historique allait
permettre de ramener le déficit à 3 %
alors qu'elle n'a servi qu'à payer vos
cadeaux électoraux vous prétendiez
ériger une république impartiale
mais depuis françois mitterrand vous
n'avez jamais autant nous n'avons jamais
vu autant d'arbitraire et de copinage en
décembre vous aviez radié du corps
préfectoral les préfet nommé par le
gouvernement précédent
le mois suivant vous nommer préfets une
cohorte de collaborateurs du parti
socialiste
nous apprenons que battu aux élections
madame royal sera nommé vice président
de la banque publique d'investissement
plus grave encore en neuf mois vous avez
proposé de changer tous les modes de
scrutin de la république pour contourner
la sanction électorale au lieu de vous
atteler aux problèmes des français
votre dernier renoncement concerne les
collectivités et l'engagement 50 cas du
candidat hollande promettait de garantir
le niveau actuel des dotations nouveau
mensonge en descendent vous avez adopté
une baisse de 2,25 milliards d'euros de
dotation pour les collectivités en
février vous proposez aussitôt de
doubler ce rabot en le portant 4,5
milliards
dois-je vous rappeler vos cris indignés
lorsque nous avions envisagé une baisse
de 0,2 milliard
même votre majorité se sont trahis
le président socialiste du cfl andré
laignel a affirmé que cela stoppe rats
les investissements des collectivités
alors qu'elles réalisent 70% des
investissements publics
le président socialiste de l'adf claudy
lebreton redoutent la perte de centaines
de milliers d'emplois principalement
dans le btp monsieur le ministre
allez-vous arrêter d'être anglais les
collectivités qui sont un support de
l'investissement dans notre beau pays a
grand besoin pour maintenir son économie
je vous remercie
merci la parole est à madame marylise
lebranchu ministre de la réforme de
l'état de la décentralisation de la
fonction publique merci monsieur le
président monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice et une partie de la question à
laquelle je crois que je ne vais pas
répondre sur les nominations les
nominations en particulier je crois que
avec le ministre l'intérieur on pourrait
faire un certain nombre de liste de
nominations récentes et vous en seriez
je pense très satisfaite compte tenu de
l' équilibre de la loyauté qui a été
celle des gens nommés donc sur cet
aspect des choses je pense qu'il faut
faire attention à ce que nous disons les
uns et les autres et la république à crs
et règles et je pense qu'elles sont
respectées mais pour en revenir à la
situation des collectivités
territoriales la situation budgétaire
je vous rappelle que pendant la campagne
électorale en particulier madame valérie
pécresse qui me l'a confirmé
tout à fait honnêtement est clairement
lors de la passation de pouvoir avait
envisagé très sérieusement 2 milliards
de baisses des dotations tous les ans
avec le ministre du budget est sous
l'autorité du premier ministre nous
avions pensé que pour la première année
même si effectivement tout était
discutable
il fallait garder une stabilité de la
ressource tels que le président de la
république l'avait proposé pour essayer
d'équilibrer cette crise violente dont
nous n'avons en aucun cas vous
l'admettrez bien volontiers la
responsabilité nous avons donc choisi de
ne pas diminuer les dotations des
collectivités territoriales pour tenir
le tissu des pme et tpe ce que qu'est ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui nous avons
besoin de faire des économies
supplémentaires
nous n'allons pas chercher 10 milliards
d'euros madame mais deux fois 1 milliard
et demi auprès des collectivités et dans
le même temps
nous prenons un engagement fort et que
j'espère vous allez entendre avec
satisfaction c'est de suivre d'abord la
première des commissions que le premier
ministre a installé pour les
départements de france parce que les
départements de france ont des
difficultés à servir les allocations
voter au niveau national et donc pour
les départements de france il faut
trouver une ressource pérenne et le
travail doit être terminés à l'été
ensuite pour l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales si la
péréquation horizontale a permis des
ajustements et encore avec des débats
difficiles
vous les avez vécu ici nous les avons
vécues à l'assemblée nationale nous nous
pensons qu'il faut revenir aussi à une
recherche de fiscalité horizontale
réécrire courageusement et tous ensemble
et le premier ministre soit réunir à cet
effet l'ensemble des présidents des
collectivités territoriales pour
travailler à une réécriture de la
dotation globale de base qui soit plus
juste
nous voulons être plus justes madame il
va nous allons effectivement demandé 1 1
25% d'efforts aux collectivités
territoriales dans la part dans la
dépense publique vous le savez est de
20% à 25% sur 244 milliards d'euros
l'ensemble des élus locaux de france
sauront le faire